[Música]
Bienvenidos a una semana en el mundo el
programa de France 24 donde los
periodistas son los invitados y
analizamos los temas que han marcado la
actualidad de la semana hoy vamos a
conversar sobre la situación de la
guerra en Ucrania también Vamos a
abordar la cobertura mediática de la
búsqueda de los cuatro menores
desaparecidos tras un accidente de
avioneta en la selva de aquí de Colombia
también veremos el panorama de Cara a
las elecciones anticipadas del 20 de
agosto en Ecuador para ello conectaremos
con quito Y también comentaremos cómo se
ha puesto sobre la mesa de nuevo el
debate del problema del racismo en
España a raíz del caso del jugador del
Real Madrid vinicius Junior y cerraremos
con un breve comentario en la antesala
de la segunda vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales de Turquía empiezo
saludando a nuestros invitados hoy nos
acompañan dos periodistas de aquí la
casa de France 24 Marta Moya cronista de
revista de prensa entre muchísimas otras
funciones bienvenida Gracias rosa con
Qué temas cierra usted la semana pues
Rosa yo creo que dos expectativas Por
una parte las elecciones en Turquía que
se van a dirimir este domingo 28 de mayo
y también el 28 de mayo ya por una
cuestión un poco más sentimental y
cercana a mí las elecciones regionales y
locales en España que también son un
poco la antesala de lo que puede llegar
a ocurrir a finales de año con las
generales ciertamente marca un tema que
seguro tocaremos aquí más adelante y
Luis Muñoz también periodista de
france24 corresponsal toca usted los
temas aquí sobre el terreno en Colombia
entre muchas otras coberturas también
sobre la actualidad internacional
bienvenido con Qué temas hay cierro
usted la semana Gracias Rosa por la
invitación yo lo cierro como comentaba
con el tema de los niños que han quedado
perdidos en la selva de Colombia después
de ese accidente y después de haber
estado en San José del guaviare pues es
un tema que es difícil perder le la
pista ciertamente lo vamos a comentar
ahora en este programa y damos la
bienvenida desde Ciudad de México a
Blanca Juárez y es periodista feminista
colabora con el medio el economista y
también con el portal sin embargo
bienvenida blanca con Qué temas cierra
usted la semana
Muchas gracias por la invitación y pues
encantada de estar en este espacio con
con ustedes colegas y pues bueno en mi
país ahí Creo que muchísimos temas ahora
y también tiene que ver algunos de ellos
con algunas escuchas el espionaje del
que ha sido víctima ahora un funcionario
de alto grado y que además es quien se
ha dedicado a defender los derechos
humanos
a investigar los casos de desapariciones
y uno de los casos más emblemáticos
desafortunadamente en México es la
desaparición de 43 normalistas
en 2015
blancas Sí abordaremos este tema
Lamentablemente en otra ocasión ahora
Les propongo empezar hablando de la
situación de la guerra en Ucrania como
avanzábamos al principio de este
programa porque esta semana ha habido
distintos acontecimientos que hacen
pensar que la situación dialogada está
más lejos que nunca a pesar de los
gestos a diplomáticos de países como
China o como Brasil que se presentan
como eventuales mediadores en este
conflicto y uno de los temas que ha
marcado la actualidad de la guerra esta
semana es que finalmente Estados Unidos
ya aceptó Ya dijo que va a permitir que
otros países envíen aviones de combate
f-16 akief y que en las próximas semanas
va a empezar el entrenamiento de pilotos
ucranianos para que sepan manejar estas
aeronaves de combate Marta empiezo por
usted le pregunto cómo va a cambiar este
armamento el curso de la guerra Pues yo
creo que aquí se plantean diferentes
escenarios Rosa porque al final
Unidos ha cedido a las presiones tanto
de kiev como también se especulaba que
el secretario de estado Anthony blinken
ha estado presionando mucho a biden para
que se diera en las últimas semanas y
meses de enviar este estos aviones de
combate a Ucrania esto puede abrir el
escenario de que evidentemente pues se
geste y se termine de materializar una
escalada en el conflicto que no se puede
dejar de lado y más cuando Rusia ya está
planteando o ya ha dicho aunque sean
materializado la entrega o la
disposición de armas tácticas nucleares
en velarus para lo que dicen es proteger
sus fronteras y también pues decía Mark
Miller y el jefe del Estado Mayor
conjunto de Estados Unidos que la
entrega sin embargo de estos aviones no
es la panacea o no es la solución mágica
para Ucrania no porque al final son
aviones muy costosos su mantenimiento
perse es muy costoso y además las
municiones de largo o sea de corto plazo
las municiones de artillería método que
ayuda mucho más a Ucrania en el día a
día pues son lo que ha venido
priorizando occidente todos estos meses
no ahora bien con el envío de f-16 al
final lo que se hace es dotar a Ucrania
eventualmente de que tenga sistemas
tanto ofensivos como defensivos más
eficientes ante una eventual escalada
por parte de Rusia pero también hay que
entender pues que no estamos ante la
solución definitiva o lo que parece que
puede ser en este conflicto del que no
se ve ninguna solución no entonces hay
que esperar un poco Cómo va ese
entrenamiento se habla de 20 pilotos que
Dinamarca y Países Bajos van a liderar
esos entrenamientos pero hay que yo creo
darle un poco más de margen y de tiempo
a este planteamiento porque ese sería
usado como hacer una un planteamiento o
una una visión muy clara de lo que puede
ocurrir Y más como está el panorama
actual en la guerra y precisamente otro
de los temas que ha marcado la
actualidad de la guerra esta semana ha
sido los en la región a rusa de velgorot
unos ataques que han sido reivindicados
por milicias de ciudadanos rusos pero
que están en contra de el gobierno del
presidente Vladimir Putin y que luchan
del bando de kiev en esta guerra sin
embargo la gran pregunta es hasta qué
punto estas milicias han cooperado o
cooperan en sus operaciones directamente
con el ejército regular ucraniano bien
esta semilicias después de reivindicar
estos ataques convocaron a la prensa en
la región ucraniana de sumi y ahí estuvo
nuestra enviada especial a Ucrania
Catalina Gómez Ángel y eso nos dijo
hablamos con los representantes de cada
uno de estos grupos la legión de Rusia
libre y el grupo de voluntarios rusos
ellos explican varias cosas que no
contaron con la ayuda de Ucrania pero sí
Ucrania sabía y los motivó Luis eh le
traslada a usted la cuestión de Qué
significa el protagonismo que cobran
estos grupos en la guerra en Ucrania en
estos momentos Parece que la guerra cada
vez pierde un poco el control también y
se fragmenta y aparecen estos grupos que
no se sabe de dónde vienen bien que
están de un carácter
ultranacionalista que es también
llamativo si ya Vladimir Putin lo
consideramos como un líder a
ultranacionalista estos grupos que estén
incluso más allá más cerca incluso a
posiciones neonazis es sorprendente como
estas disidencias oposiciones que tiene
Rusia sean de este carácter y volviendo
un poco a lo que comentaba al principio
está fragmentación lo que comentaba
antes Marta estos aviones f-16 que será
lo próximo ya no la la como que la
guerra está llegando un punto en el que
ya lo próximo es las armas nucleares
Mientras tanto también los sondeos en
Estados Unidos cada vez indican más que
la población está cansada de este envío
de armas también del envío de dinero
etcétera y que cada vez mundialmente se
siente de de forma externa unas ansias
mayores para la paz pero de forma
interna pues estos estas milicias que
aparecen Incluso el ataque con drones al
kremlin Parece que fue obra de la
inteligencia ucraniana Y que ni
bolodinsky tenía información sobre esto
es como se está perdiendo un poco el
control mientras todo va escalando y ya
estamos por los aviones f-16 y qué será
lo próximo en el conflicto Sí una una
pregunta que se hace pues gran parte de
la comunidad internacional Luis
exactamente y en relación a lo que usted
comentaba de este ataque del kremlin
apuntemos que fue el New York Times que
en esta semana reveló que según la
inteligencia estadounidense creo que
podemos ver el gráfico de ese artículo
en las pantallas según inteligencia
estadounidense este ataque de drones
contra el kremlin habría sido obra de la
inteligencia militar o de espías
ucranianos pero la duda una vez más es
hasta qué punto estaba coordinada con
digamos y con el presidente
para ir cerrando con este bloque blanca
le pregunto En estos momentos y usted
precisamente cómo lo ve desde el
continente americano pero desde América
Latina una región que no sea posicionado
tan claramente con ninguno de los bandos
estos esfuerzos diplomáticos que están
siendo protagonizados tanto por china
como también por Brasil estos intentos
de mediación mientras como bien
comentaba nuestro compañero Luis están
desplegándose ya armas nucleares
tácticas en la frontera bueno en velarus
pero como respuesta a la escalada en
este conflicto
parece que no tenemos buena conexión con
México en estos momentos pero mientras
arreglamos estos problemas técnicos
Marta le traslado esta pregunta que qué
lugar para la diplomacia un lugar
bastante complejo y dada un poco la
polarización que ha traído también este
conflicto no una posición muy marcada de
los aliados occidentales con bolodimir
zelemski y luego pues tenemos a China o
otras grandes potencias que han decidido
mantenerse al margen Blanca parece que
hemos recuperado esta conexión
recuperamos esa pregunta
Muchísimas gracias Sí te decía que
agradezco mucho esa pregunta porque
precisamente desde nuestros territorios
en México y en lo que ahora conocemos
como América Latina de pronto quizá
podemos pensar que estos temas no nos
competen tanto y o no nos afectan tanto
cuando realmente en primer lugar estamos
viendo eh miles de Vidas perdidas miles
y millones de Vidas afectadas ha tenido
un fuerte impacto en la economía mundial
y pues creo que países que hemos sido
invadidos y hemos sido colonizados como
México y otros países más de América
Latina estamos precisamente llamados y
las las personas periodistas llamadas a
poner atención Precisamente en esta
guerra y hacerlo desde una desde una
perspectiva crítica también así que sí
me parece súper importante esto esto que
preguntas y ha sido Quizás sí desde
México no sea querido pronunciar de
manera directa ha ido un poco
sorteando con esta política que el
gobierno de México
enarbola de no interferir en las
decisiones de otros países sin embargo
eh Sí cada es ha sido algo constante que
Rusia en la ONU proponga el el no
proliferar en mensajes que tenga que ver
con el nazismo o con el fascismo eh
México había estado a favor de de evitar
ese tipo de mensajes de condenar esos
mensajes y esta vez eh se abstuvo así
que me parece que eso sería un mensaje
Ya al menos de de cómo ha moderado su
política y pues bueno también un poco de
lo que hablaban mis mis compañeras mis
compañeros sobre este riesgo ya de irse
hacia un un nivel nuclear también me
parece que Pues habría que poner el
punto regresarnos un poquito a este
envío también de de proyectiles de
uranio empobrecido que el Reino Unido
anunció que enviaría y luego esto Pues
bueno la respuesta de de Putin de
pues llevar armas que de táctica nuclear
a Bielorrusia y para cerrar este bloque
uno de los temas que han marcado
definitivamente esta semana en la Guerra
de Ucrania ha sido que el grupo Wagner
ya proclamó a tener el control total de
bacmut y empezó a entregar sus
posiciones al ejército regular de Moscú
Cómo cambia esto el curso de la guerra
estaríamos al fin de lo que ha sido la
batalla más larga de este conflicto Luis
si es vista como una victoria más bien
propagandística en tanto que bajmund no
es un enclave especialmente importante
de como una ruta de paso ni con grandes
industrias pero si es donde se ha puesto
Pues digamos en términos bélicos toda la
carne en el asador o sea tanto Rusia
como Ucrania han sufrido miles de bajas
y han estado durante meses compitiendo
pues tener el control de esta ciudad y
poder anotarse un tanto una victoria
después de meses sobre todo Rusia en los
que no había podido avanzar y de este
modo sí que pueden seguir avanzando
hacia el don Bass que es el objetivo
final para el ejército Ruso y cómo
estarán de debilitadas las tropas
ucranianas no Y también como habrá
afectado Pues a las fuerzas del grupo
Wagner es una incógnita que comparten
analistas internacionales alrededor del
planeta Les propongo ahora que cambiemos
a otra cuestión que también ha marcado
la actualidad de estas últimas semanas y
se trata de la búsqueda de los cuatro
menores indígenas desaparecidos después
de que la avioneta en la que viajaban
junto con a tres adultos se estrellara
en la selva de aquí de Colombia los tres
adultos fallecieron en el incidente
mientras que los cuatro menores están en
estos momentos desaparecidos y el caso
ha traído la atención de la prensa
alrededor del mundo y particularmente
usted Luis estuvo ahí estuvo en el
guaviare pues movido no por este por
este caso Le pregunto después de estar
ahí Cuál es su análisis de la situación
del caso de la historia la historia
genera interés al final porque lo
podemos trasladar a una película un
guión de una película o de una serie y
funcionaría desde el primero de mayo que
es cuando sale esa avioneta con siete
personas sale la noticia de que una
avioneta se pierde no volvemos a saber
nada y a las dos semanas se reporta que
ha aparecido la avioneta los tres
adultos están muertos mientras que los
niños no aparecen hay rastros alrededor
del avión se ha encontrado pues Un
refugio improvisado también unas tijeras
un biberón pañales zapatillas se han
encontrado distintas cosas lo que no han
encontrado no es ni a los niños tampoco
Rastros de sangre que es la pregunta
cómo pueden unos adultos morir en un
accidente y unos niños sobrevivir todo
esto genera mucho misterio genera mucha
curiosidad genera muchas preguntas
especialmente también cuando hemos
estado allá en San José del guaviares la
capital del departamento del guaviare
desde allá Es que el ejército ha hecho
todas sus operaciones de rescate con
helicópteros aviones yendo al medio de
la selva que es donde cayó la avioneta y
una zona donde se cree que hay
diferencias de la guerrilla también
comunidades no contactadas de indígenas
o sea tiene todos los ingredientes como
para que sea una película y por el
momento la respuesta más importante que
es sobre todo De dónde están los niños
Todavía no se ha logrado esa respuesta
usted me lo comentaba antes no puramente
como humanos son pues misterios que
inevitablemente interesan y esto en
contraste a lo que suelen interesar
Generalmente los aspectos que tocan a
las poblaciones in no solo en Colombia
sino a lo largo y ancho del continente
americano Cómo ve este contraste Luis es
incluso perverso porque en los mismos
días en que se estaba realizando la
búsqueda más a fondo y empezaba a
hacerse cada vez más mediática la
historia al mismo tiempo en el mismo
departamento en el caquetán bueno
fronterizo con el guainía con el
guaviare con todos estos departamentos
amazónicos en el caquetá se producían la
masacre de cuatro niños de cuatro
adolescentes que habían sido reclutados
forzosamente por una de estos grupos
criminales que se hacen llamar como
disidencias de las FARC una masacre que
se produjo después de ese reclutamiento
los niños escaparon llegaron las
licencias a las comunidades y fueron
masacrados que es por esto que se ha
levantado Pues el cese de las
hostilidades que el gobierno de Gustavo
Petro había declarado pero no solo estos
jóvenes también en la misma semana
mientras estábamos en San José de
guaviare una niña de una comunidad
indígena había muerto por una gripa o
nos podemos ir al norte del país al
Caribe que es la zona más para que es la
guajira donde al mes de abril más de 20
niños habían muerto por desnutrición y
que señalan muy bien estas condiciones
que tienen de fragilidad la infancia
Pero especialmente las infancias de las
poblaciones étnicas efectivamente y
precisamente ahí en el guaviare
118 militares no según señaló el propio
presidente Gustavo Petro a principios de
este año están investigados por
violencia sexuales contra menores
indígenas no le trasladó esta pregunta a
ustedes de México Blanca Cómo ve este
contraste entre la atención que ha
centrado esta búsqueda de los cuatro
menores respecto a la atención que se
suele poner desde los medios a la
situación de las comunidades indígenas
en América Latina
sí creo que es una prueba súper
importante para para los medios de
comunicación
también hubo ha habido informaciones
falsas que incluso
ha tenido que desmentir y que ha dicho
ha emitido el propio gobierno colombiano
hace hace unos días el el presidente
Gustavo Petro dio a conocer que ya se
habían encontrado a a las niñas y los
niños y luego tuvo que
corregir y decir que esto no es cierto
Por una parte esto nos muestra que las
personas que estamos cubriendo cualquier
tipo de noticia no podemos fiarnos ni
siquiera de las fuentes que
Aparentemente son oficiales sobre todo
en temas como estos en los que hay
muchísimas irregularidades hay muchas
cosas que son
imposibles todavía de de saber y esto
Además nos nos lleva a la cobertura que
se tiene de pronto
de las personas indígenas de cómo se les
llena de estereotipos también cuando
también en en muchos conflictos de estos
hay diferentes matices Cómo se
criminaliza a las familias a los padres
a las madres cuando las niñas y niños
indígenas están sufriendo de diferentes
vulneraciones a sus derechos humanos
creo que al final es es una prueba súper
difícil en la que vamos a tener que
revisar la manera en la que habíamos
hecho la cobertura de
de las comunidades indígenas de los
conflictos en América Latina conflictos
armados que en América Latina hay
muchísimos y pues al al final
cuando se declara la paz Esto no es de
no se resuelve todo de un día para otro
hay todavía un gran proceso y esto
también nos está mostrando los
resultados y y lo que queda aún todavía
de de esos conflictos y precisamente
Blanca en relación a lo que usted
comentaba la estigmatización de los
pueblos indígenas este caso sin embargo
en una situación inédita el estado de
Colombia está valorando mucho el
conocimiento de los pueblos indígenas
sobre el territorio y particularmente
sobre la selva no y Luis usted trató
este tema precisamente desde ahí desde
el guaviare Nos mandó un informe del
cual hemos seleccionado un fragmento que
grabó junto a nuestro compañero aitor
chavarri veamos los indígenas están
siendo clave en la búsqueda de los niños
como Leandro Ibáñez de la comunidad
siona es uno de los 25 guardias
procedentes de las comunidades
amazónicas de caqueta y putumayo han
llegado a San José del guaviare el
centro de la operación esperanza de
rescate lo hacen Para apoyar a las
fuerzas armadas en la búsqueda de los
abuelos ancestrales que nos guían y no
abran ese para nosotros poder llegar al
territorio y encontrar aquellos niños
que están desaparecidos Luis
precisamente Cómo valora esta esta
cooperación Sí al margen de esa
sabiduría ancestral es muy curioso que
los militares junto con los indígenas
estén todos desplazados en la Zona cero
donde fue el accidente y estén buscando
a los niños y es muy curioso de forma
anecdótica y muy breve cuando llegaron
ese grupo de indígenas que venían de
distintas partes del país el general al
mando el comandante Pedro Sánchez lo
recibió al grito de Yo soy yo también
soy indígena y les y les emplazó a hacer
conjuntamente la búsqueda y valorando el
trabajo que hacen en las comunidades
donde no llegan el estado dentro de los
pueblos indígenas de Colombia esas
conocidas como guardias indígenas ese
reconocimiento es novedoso cuando
normalmente ha habido más enfrentamiento
que alianzas normalmente en Colombia por
supuesto un reconocimiento bueno
imprescindible no en Colombia en
cualquier país de América Latina Marta
no sé si usted tiene algo que Añadir al
respecto de
como yo
monitoreo mucho la prensa internacional
todo esto ya a nivel fuera de Colombia
estalló una vez Petro publica ese tuit
que luego sale a desmentir he leído
artículos en la prensa china hablando de
este caso y al final pues es un caso que
no tiene mucho más recorrido porque está
plagado de incógnitas no Y además nos
habla mucho de lo que es el
sensacionalismo la búsqueda de clics y
un poco pues esa búsqueda de la noticia
clickbait en los medios de comunicación
que al final no tienen más respuestas de
lo que dice la selva de momento
Exactamente Bueno Les propongo que
pasemos a un país donde los pueblos
indígenas tienen muchísimo peso a nivel
político hablamos de Ecuador donde el
Consejo Nacional electoral ya ha
establecido el próximo 20 de agosto como
fecha para las elecciones anticipadas
que se desencadenaron a raíz del decreto
de muerte Cruzada con el que el
presidente Guillermo lasso disolvió la
asamblea nacional y anticipó así las
elecciones tanto
presidenciales como legislativas ahí se
encuentra nuestro enviado especial
Rodrigo sedano Rodrigo le saludo desde
aquí desde Bogotá
Rodrigo empecemos comentando Cuál es el
ambiente allí en la capital de Ecuador
en Quito entre la población Cómo se ven
estas elecciones con un cierto
entusiasmo de Cara a desbloquear una
crisis política o más bien ya con
desafección
pues Rosa entusiasmo he visto más bien
poco durante estos días que hemos estado
aquí en Quito en la capital del país lo
que nos dice la gente es que les da
igual que ya no haya asamblea que están
hartos de los políticos en el país hay
una desafección enorme conforme a lo que
pasaba en esa asamblea que cerró
precisamente el presidente Guillermo
lasso Y esto no significa que no tengan
preferencias hay mucha gente que nos
dice que volvería a votar por lasso que
esa asamblea le ha hecho la vida
imposible Durante los dos años que ha
tenido de mandato y mucha gente también
que busca que vuelva el correísmo
hablaban allí en el estudio también de
los pueblos indígenas pachacútec el
partido de la confederación de las
nacionalidades indígenas del Ecuador va
a ser clave precisamente ayer estuvieron
todo el día reunidos para buscar a su
candidato pero como le digo mucha
desafección mucho cansancio ya de la
clase política aquí en Ecuador y Rodrigo
Cuáles son los temas que la población
espera que se traten en esta campaña
para básicamente pues luchar un poco
contra la desafección y pensar que se
puede hacer algo para mejorar la
situación del país
bueno los temas son dos principalmente
el primero de ellos es la gran
inseguridad que estaba viviendo el país
quizás no tanto acá en Quito ayer sí que
estuvimos haciendo un reportaje en uno
de los barrios populares de la ciudad
donde sí que nos mencionaban que ha
crecido la inseguridad pero donde más se
ve es en Guayaquil y en la provincia de
esmeraldas al norte del país allí
realmente hay un gran problema y ya los
candidatos están lanzando sus eslóganes
para intentar mediar en esta grave En
este grave problema de inseguridad ha
surgido una figura y antrópica una
outsider un ex militar dice que ha
participado de la legión extranjera
francesa ese cuerpo de élite que ha
luchado en África que ha luchado en
Siria y que ha estado también en Ucrania
se declara admirador de nayib bukele
Pero por otro lado por la izquierda
hemos podido hablar también con los
correístas y nos dicen que hay que dar
mano dura sin ningún tipo de sin ningún
tipo de duda para este de la inseguridad
pero claro el problema es cómo hacerlo
sin caer en esas denuncias de respeto a
los Derechos Humanos por otro lado está
también la inseguridad económica de
muchas familias nos han comentado que la
situación no es realmente mala pero si
han visto que en los últimos años ha
bajado la capacidad de las familias que
hoy también hemos podido estar hablando
del tema de los medicamentos a veces
faltan medicamentos y lo que nos
comentan es que muchas veces se ha
hablado de las clases más desfavorecidas
pero está llegando a la clase media esa
falta de poder adquisitivo para
enfrentar la compra de medicamentos
Rodrigo pues muchísimas gracias por este
reporte le esperamos aquí en Bogotá a su
regreso ya bien próximo con los brazos
abiertos
y precisamente quiero Blanca desde
México que nos dé un poco su impresión
de la panorama de Cara a las elecciones
de Ecuador
gracias Pues creo que por un lado es una
oportunidad para para participar sin
embargo justamente este reporte que que
nos envía Rodrigo me parece peligroso es
decir esta desafección puede también
impedir la participación política de las
personas en un momento de crisis nunca
en en la historia de Ecuador se había
utilizado esta herramienta que les que
le permite su ley al al presidente
deshacer la asamblea y que como
requisito o como obligación una vez de
hecho esto Llamar a a elecciones por un
lado es una oportunidad para la
izquierda
Regresar al poder tampoco les va a ser
fácil porque precisamente como
mencionabas al inicio hay es un es un
país con una fuerte población indígena
que no llegó del todo a
esta conexión con el correísmo sí se
apoyó muchísimo desde muchos de los
pueblos indígenas desde las
organizaciones sin embargo muchas
también pensaron que les quedaron a
deber es quizá también esperanzador el
escuchar a Rodrigo como nos dice que
están ya también
organizándose para elegir a sus
candidatos o sus candidatas pero pues
bueno al final
todavía Creo que queda mucho camino la
primera vez que que se realiza como les
decía que que vemos este escenario en
Ecuador y pues en un contexto de una
gran inseguridad este el regreso de las
de los gobiernos de derechas a Ecuador
pues eh en las cifras lo que nos muestra
es que hubo un retroceso un retroceso en
la seguridad en el aumento de homicidios
y tantos Así que el propio gobierno de
lasso emitió un decreto para que las
personas pudieran portar armas después
se les dijo pero
esto es increíble es y otra pues
conexión con con gobiernos de derecha
como las de como el de Trump por ejemplo
de pues armar a la población para que
sean las que se protegen y el estado se
se hace a un lado sí totalmente Blanca
lazo uno de los pocos políticos de
derecha que quedan en la región a
latinoamericana Luis le trasladó
rápidamente este análisis sobre el
panorama en Ecuador Parece que va a ser
un panorama contracorriente tanto la
preparación electoral que normalmente es
para un año Ahora va a ser cuestión de
meses la campaña todo va a ser como
rápidamente por esta muerte Cruzada que
como señalaban la compañera blanca Es la
primera vez que se produce y no solo
será contracorriente esta campaña sino
el presidente que gane solo tendrá un
año y medio para presidir porque en 2025
Se volverá a acabar el mandato y no es
nadie sabe si es tiempo suficiente para
solucionar estos problemas que nos
señalaba Rodrigo especialmente el de la
inseguridad en Guayaquil los homicidios
están Lamentablemente disparados
completamente Seguiremos muy de cerca
toda la campaña en Ecuador y para ir
cerrando le pido un comentario sobre un
tema que sé que usted ha seguido muy de
cerca y es el caso de vinicius Junior el
jugador del Real Madrid
cuyos ataques racistas contra él ha
desatado el debate sobre el racismo en
España hay tres imputados por delitos de
odio considera que mediatizar este caso
no y ponerlo sobre la mesa va a ayudar a
combatir el racismo en España siempre es
importante señalar el foco y mediatizar
este tipo de casos no sé si la solución
es que estas imputaciones van a ser la
solución sino creo que es un problema
más estructural en España y viene
también pues de muchas veces los
altavoces mediáticos que se han dado a
ciertos discursos de ultraderecha
racistas También muchas veces en contra
de poblaciones migrantes que también
hace que ciertas personas sientan que
tengan un altavoz por contra quiero
decir también por un poco de un mensaje
más esperanzador la situación en España
hoy es mucho mejor que la que era de 30
años Cuando un presidente como el de
aquel entonces Jesús Gil del Atlético de
Madrid se permitía decir en público que
le iba a cortar el cuello al negro en
referencia al tren Valencia entonces la
situación contextual ha mejorado pero sí
que es verdad que queda mucho camino
todavía por recorrer mucho y ahí y hay
quienes analistas que han dicho que
quizás este este tema no este es estos
condenas contra el racismo pueden
incluso influir a las elecciones de este
domingo en España que bien mencionaba
antes Marta y hablando de elecciones
solo les voy a pedir un comentario muy
rápido su pronóstico consideran que
erdogan va a mantenerse en el poder en a
Turquía o que finalmente la oposición va
a lograr la alternancia de la mano del
líder de la coalición que mallo con ese
49,5% de la primera vuelta que consiguió
erdogan parece difícil que no vaya a
ganar este domingo Marta yo creo lo
mismo que lluis al final a pesar de la
radicalización del discurso de que lidar
oglu sin anogan decidió que iba a apoyar
a erdogan lo tiene bastante hecho yo
creo tal Y verdogan este domingo y
blanca le pido a usted también un rápido
pronóstico sobre las elecciones en
Turquía de domingo gracias Pues sí
coincido con mi compañera mi compañero
la verdad es que se ve bastante difícil
que que le puedan dar la vuelta y ahí
más bien lo que quisiera decir es pues
el peligro de metabolizar todos estos
discursos de odio y de racismo de
islamofobia y y pues todos estos
discursos que que trae la extrema
derecha completamente y está como usted
lo decía Marta está radicalización de
todos los candidatos en Turquía
finalmente bueno llegamos así al final
de esta Edición de una semana en el
mundo Recuerden que aquí en France 24 va
a haber programación especial de Cara a
las elecciones de Turquía este domingo
lo podrán seguir en vivo aquí a través
de france24 de nuestras redes sociales o
de France 24.com Muchísimas gracias por
su atención nos vemos en una semana
Muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes
[Música]